so after logistic regression we're going
to start talking about um which was
using stats models we'll start using
some of the classifiers from Psych learn
so the first one we will fit is this LDA
model um so the way uh pych learn works
for these prediction problems is there's
some object um in this case we've called
it LDA that was just a shorthand for
linear discrimin analysis um that sort
of tells we don't give any data to the
the the classifying object here we just
give some arguments like in this case we
asked it to store the co-variance in
case we want to inspect the co-variance
Matrix in LDA but having formed the
estimator this way we later fit on uh M
Matrix of features and a response why
and then we can predict on new features
or the original features so that's the
general way that these estimators all
work okay so we're again going to um
uh split into test and training and so
we'll make our uh our um training and
test sets uh as follows and we're going
to fit on the training data so Jonathan
we're using the same train and test um
design matrices we had before but you
just dropping The Intercept from the Z
right uh that's right yeah yes yes
because LDA doesn't require you to put
it into
yes and and I think it will actually uh
complain because the uh well because the
coari will be zero so yes it will have a
non-invertible
ciance
um okay so as we saw in the lecture
there are a few different parameters
that come from fitting the LDA model one
is the uh the common covariance uh there
are within class means that you can find
this way um there's the label of which
class is which this just helps if down
is the first one that tells tells us
that um now this is 2 by two I we'll
have the documentation again as s learn
has great documentation we tell us
whether uh the mean the second row is
the mean in the class or the second
column um uh is the mean of the up um if
we had used a three features we would be
able to tell here because we would have
a 2x3 or a 3x2 matrix but the
documentation we'll sort it out my my my
guess is that it goes by row as the
major or met index
but okay so these these quantities are
parameters of the um of the fitted model
and this scalings Matrix here this
actually tells you the discriminant
function that's what's used to to to
tell to make the prediction between
whether uh you're in the up class or the
down class
okay so we'll want to again evaluate how
well this uh classifier does on uh the
test data so so we'll use now the the
second method that's commonly used for
psychic learn classifiers in any case
it's the predict method having fit on X
train and Y train we predict on X test
and will again form the confusion
Matrix uh using the same function we
have the same uh test labels so we don't
we haven't printed out the uh well let's
see if we print
it we have not printed out the accuracy
um yeah but
so let's move on okay so we'll just
pause here for a moment to say that most
of the time we've we've estimate we've
we've assigned points to classes based
on
thresholding the probability at
50%
um though sometimes we might you know we
might decide to change that uh and we
can easily eily uh do that by just uh
changing the um the threshold we apply
to these prob these probabilities this
LDA probability Vector these are the
estimated class probabilities for um for
the the prediction the the test data so
the First Column is the pro estimated
probability of being in the up class and
the second column is the estimated
probability of being in the down class
so I guess if you increase the threshold
you'll classify less observations in up
clause and more in the down Clause
that's right and that'll change those
two off diagonal errors that you have in
in the confusion Matrix yes and I I just
I saw in the text that it's actually the
first column is the down class so what
the effect that will be is if we
increase the threshold to 90% we'll just
predict fewer in the down and the number
in this row will get smaller uh but hope
it's possible that the accuracy will
improve uhu um by well depending on the
balance of how many are uh up up and
down and the within class
accuracy okay so let's move on to our
our next classifier the next classifier
is quadratic discrimin analysis or qda
and remember that this is very similar
to LDA the main difference is that there
is a class specific covariance Matrix um
so in terms of code we're going to fit
it it as promised it fits almost
identical to LDA we have the same uh
training features and the same training
labels we'll call the fit method on qda
and this little qda is a is an instance
of the the qda classifier and again
we've asked it to store the covariances
so with this we can for instance look at
the uh the within within the down class
covariance that would be the the first
covariant entry of the covariance uh
returned so just to remind you because
we now now our separate coverance Matrix
in in each of the classes two in this
case the the classification function
becomes a quadratic function that's
right whereas by having that convenient
assumption that they were the same if
they were the same that led to linear
discriminant analysis was a linear
function that's right so the in the the
the discriminant function in qda is not
described just by The scalings Matrix
you need both the covariance and the
difference in means the scalings in the
LDA example is is essentially the
difference in means well multiplied by
the inverse of The covariance Matrix
okay so again in order to evaluate how
well this classifier is doing we can uh
we use the predict method on our test
label our test features and then we use
the same confusion uh Matrix or the
confusion table function to produce the
confusion
Matrix okay and so here we see the QD is
about 60% accurate that's even better
than uh I think we had
55% accuracy with the the these features
in logistic regression so this is
actually quite good for um for the
financial data
so okay so hopefully you now see the
pattern having having seen it twice for
two different classifiers this SK learn
it's you know once you know this the
pattern it's quite easy to fit many
different classifiers so we have a few
more to fit um one is naive Bay and then
we'll wrap up with uh K nearest neighbor
classifier so
recall from the lectures or in you can
read in the textbook that the naive Bays
when you have continuous features naive
Bas is essentially is quite closely
related to to qda it's just sort of a a
restricted version of quadratic
discrimin analysis in terms of um of the
code uh again it is fit and uh
identically to qda and LDA we call the
fit method on our training features and
training labels and then we'll evaluate
uh in a similar fashion so I mentioned
it's quite related to
qda uh essentially it just imposes the
constraint that the diag the coari matri
are diagonal for qda that's basically
the difference between naive Bay and qda
so it's a simpler model it has fewer
parameters than qda but otherwise quite
similar um
okay so uh just like qda and LDA there
are within class parameters that you can
um that you can
uh examine as the output of an i Bas for
instance
uh the the the cience Matrix being
diagonal means within class you only
have to store the variance of each
feature to describe the diagonal matrix
rather than the covariance so this
variance underscore attribute has the uh
within class covariance maty the
variances of the lag one and lag two for
class zero and class one or class class
down and class
up okay and if you want to see more
about what these attributes are if you
look at the help for the naive Bay
object it will describe it will have a
its dock string that describes what
these attributes are and that's similar
for the LDA object and the qda object if
you're ever curious about how to find
their
names okay so let's see how well our
naive Bas
predicts
um it's we form the confusion table
similar fashion and we get around 59%
very close to LDA
um so they're all doing all these um
discriminant analysis methods are doing
reasonably well yes yeah okay so our
next topic will be K's
Neighbors